hello good evening everyone i'm lynne
cooley the dean of the graduate school
of arts and sciences
i am pleased to welcome you to our
second presentation in a series of
conversations with yale graduate school
alumni
sponsored by the graduate school and
it's a wonderful alumni board
this series called perspectives
is meant to bridge our alumni and
student communities
sharing alumni experiences and insights
as both models for success
and for opening opportunities for alumni
and students to connect
i have ambitious goals for transforming
and evolving yale's approach to doctoral
education as well as plans to strengthen
and build our alumni community to
connect our faculty administrators and
students more frequently and to help
ignite those connections in support of
our students
i look forward to using what we learned
from this series to think about how we
can improve continue to improve graduate
student experiences for all students at
yale
today tonight we will be joined by
lindsay mcmillan-brown phd alumna from
the department of chemical and
environmental engineering
tariq fadow ph.d assistant director of
the marble center for cancer
nanomedicine at mit
and our own danica tisdale fisher
assistant dean for diversity here at the
graduate school
we hope that you will enjoy this
conversation about lindsay's scholarship
and the lessons she has learned from her
days as a graduate student at yale and
beyond i'm delighted to have so many
graduate students and alumni and a few
faculty i see on the list tuning in from
around the world and i hope you will
enjoy the conversation
thank you lennon good evening everyone
my name is danica tisdale fisher and i
am assistant dean of diversity here at
the yale graduate school
before we get started i'd like to share
a few housekeeping items with you
we will be recording this webinar
and we'll share the recording after the
conversation
we are offering closed captioning
technology which you can access by
clicking the live broadcast link in the
top left hand corner of your screen
in the second half of the session we
will be saving time for questions and
answers
many graduate students and alumni have
submitted questions in advance
and we also hope you will enter
additional questions in the q a box
during this webinar
now i am delighted to introduce lindsay
macmillan-brown
[Music]
dr mcmillan-brown is a research
electrical engineer at nasa glenn
research center where she focuses on
solar cell materials development
she is currently the principal
investigator of a 2.5 million dollar
early career initiative developing a new
class of solar cells that can be
manufactured in space and on the moon
prior to joining nasa
lindsey earned her phd in chemical
engineering at yale university in 2019
where she researched novel materials and
nano patterns for advanced light
trapping in solar cells
outside of the lab lindsey is dedicated
to increasing opportunities for
underrepresented individuals in stem
fields
she challenges institutions to commit to
cultural changes
that provide more supportive
environments for their students
we will be talking about her experience
today and her recommendations for how
research spaces can be more inclusive
dr tarak haddel will start our
conversation about transitioning from
graduate school to a career in the
sciences
thanks so much danica can you guys hear
me okay
it is a pleasure to be here uh like
lindsay i'm a fellow ellen from the yale
school of engineering and applied
science and shortly after a postdoc at
yale i spent well it's been what 10
years now which is crazy i spent several
years in in science policy focusing in
the field of nanoscience and emerging
technologies in washington dc and now i
manage a research center at mit uh
called the marvel center for
nanomedicine i am so excited uh to
pursue this conversation and and lindsay
what what an amazing professional
journey you've had so far
um i i really wanted to start from the
beginning and and ask you a little bit
more about how you first fell in love
with science and and how did you
ultimately end up in nasa
well good evening everyone and i'm so
happy to be here with all of you today
um and tarek that's a great starting
point
i fell in love with science from a
really early age i was fortunate that
both of my parents were really
enthusiastic about science
so i got a lot of hands-on experience
with my dad outside you know tinkering
with the cars doing nature walks and
hikes and gathering catching animals
that we could um and my mom was really
uh you know had the textbooks in order
so we were learning things in the house
and getting those math skills together
and all those things um so that really
you know was a great introduction to
science i went to space camp as a kid
and that was amazing it's a fun
experience i would recommend it 10 out
of 10. so i had a really great time you
know doing different science camps um
and having that type of exposure
which is a privilege that you know not
everyone gets access to but those
experiences really did
help me fall in love with science and
then i ended up at nasa through more
experiences doing internships so
early in college i
applied for a summer internship
opportunity
and that just so happened to be in the
field of solar cells
i was always you know an
environmentalist and i
thought that i knew solar cells were
kind of important um and but i had no
idea how they worked and the science
behind them uh so it was at that first
internship that i was exposed to the
research behind them and the science and
the engineering and i loved the
technology and i loved how i felt i felt
like i was making a difference in the
world and really making a positive
contribution so i was hooked at that
point and i continued through nasa as an
intern and then i joined their co-op
program and now i'm happy to say i'm a
civil servant there today
it's amazing i you know a lot of times i
have have
many conversations um you know with
graduate students postdoc actually a
couple of them actually in the in the
participant list here tonight and and
it's it's you know remarkable because
they asked me a lot of times
when you think about this journey is it
a linear journey or are there like many
pivots along the way i see you've done a
lot of you know internships you've been
able to to kind of just fall in love
with with you know with the stars right
and and and think a little bit more
about how to get there and you've had
internships through it you went through
space camp earlier on um but did you
ever feel like well maybe you know i
could use solar powers and commercial
applications maybe i could shift there
you know was it more of like a process
of elimination or was it kind of like i
know what i'm going to do and i'm going
to head there i'm gonna just be bold and
go for it
yeah i think i was fortunate enough to
be able to realize the goal and decide
you know i would love to do solar panels
and i'd love to do them at nasa and
fortunately those those doors swung open
for me so i was able to stay on that
path um and i did a lot of exploration
along the way but i still kind of had
that end goal
in mind so i did some research on
medical devices uh along the way i was
able to work at johnson and johnson and
engineer a bit of medical devices uh so
i had you know some diverse experiences
and i've definitely flirted with you
know the idea of some other things
there's so much so many fun things to do
um i was a mechanical engineering major
and undergrad and i was very entranced
by cars so i thought i would be in the
automotive industry maybe um you know
designing the next generation of cars
and then you see that as an actual
engineer you're like working on a screw
that goes in the left door panel of the
car um so that became you know a little
a little less attractive but
i was really interested in a lot of
different things but solar has really
been the home for me
it's um it's it's amazing to hear that i
you know you mentioned your parents i um
a lot of these discussions about how the
tales of pivots are or jumps from one
adventure to another in the world of
science
is
you know it can be driven a lot of times
by
you know your passion for what you do
you know what you tinker with or what
you work on but a lot of times it is the
engagement and we'll we'll get to that
later as well but with the people right
and you mentioned how you know your
parents kind of just you know kind of
inspired you to to go through all the
space camps had the the books you know
stacked up and ready to go but um
do you feel that that played a big role
as well in terms of of how where you
ended up at the end or
absolutely it was a huge role and i
think the biggest thing that my parents
enabled for me that i didn't even
realize necessarily or appreciate until
i got much older was that they
instilled these skills and the belief
that i belonged in any space that i was
interested in so it was fine i mean they
encouraged the fact that i like to get
outside and get dirty there weren't
things for boys versus girls and there
weren't you know spaces that maybe you
don't want to do this they encouraged it
and nurtured it
and gave me those experiences that they
saw excited me
so that really you know allowed me to
view the world as endless possibilities
and i didn't have any limitations on
myself
that's great i you know i want to talk
more about these endless possibilities i
want to shift a little bit more to
um to think a little bit more let's
let's continue in that realm of pivots
and um you know as you know more than
anyone here often in space we go from
very very hot to
very very very cold and i could
probably say the same about graduate
school sometimes when it comes to
you know what you do in the lab and
experiencing successes and failure i
remember back in the days you know if my
cell culture got contaminated oh my
goodness it was it was the end of the
world then and then when the experiment
worked it's kind of like right it's just
the best feeling in the world and so you
know i'm just
yell is such an amazing place and it is
so unique and there's
such a breadth of resources and the
people there and i just i just want to
hear a little bit more about how you
manage these ups and downs while you
were there
yeah so i took kind of a multi-faceted
approach to managing those ups and downs
and one of the key things was having a
support system and a support network so
um i had the support network of my
family that you know was ready made and
always there with me and for me
but then i also had this new support
network that i was building at yale and
that consisted of the friends that i
made organically on campus um and they
were interdisciplinary studying
different things and we supported each
other through the hot and cold the ups
and downs and trials and tribulations of
the graduate school journey and then in
many instances there would not
necessarily be the exact support
that i wanted around and in those
instances
i would get together with friends on
campus and we would build it ourselves
and i think that's important to do
because
a lot of times we are in spaces that
we're not
uh are not yet ready for people like us
to be in so you know women in stem or
people of color in these you know
tremendously uh
new environments that have been
historically underrepresenting people so
it's important that we make space and
claim space that we need to support us
through these times um and for me that
looked like uh co-founding the society
of women engineers with some women in
the chemical and environmental
engineering program
that was co-founding the yale league of
black scientists with
two physicists charles brown and brooke
russell
and also
i found a great home at the university
church at yale um and that was where i
really felt community and felt welcome
and it wasn't you know the stem support
um and it wasn't in my field or
discipline but it really fed my soul and
it you know we sometimes forget uh that
we are whole people and you know i
needed to nourish my whole self so i was
able to kind of build that support
network across campus in many different
places
i i love that and nourishing yourself is
definitely you know kind of um
uh you know just just a recurring kind
of quality that that field that
you know all of us kind of need
throughout this journey in graduate
school and beyond and um it's just
remarkable how much of a moment when
certainty can be when you feel like
you're dwelling yourself into
a subject of research whether it's in
the sciences or beyond and a lot of the
it seems like a lot of kind of your
existence kind of revolves around it and
it's just um it's great and i wanted to
just you know
kind of just remember how enabling that
landscape on campus was but also to not
just forget about i mean you started a
sui chapter right can you tell us a
little more i mean it it you know i i
love how you glass but really it was
amazing and you and it took a lot of
effort
and uh just being able to convince
yourself and then
seeing around you and just being like
you know what we need this and can you
tell us a bit more how did that happen
yeah so that was that was definitely a
proud moment in in grad school and that
came from
a group of us women grad students you
know sitting in mason lab at lunch um
talking about well at my undergrad you
know we had this and my undergrad had
this and that's what we need around here
you know gripe ripe grumble grumble um
and finally we had kicked it around
enough and we were actually telling the
undergrads um that were also in the
engineering departments uh you know
telling them these tall tales of what
our sweet chapters used to do and how we
felt community there and how you know
what a rich experience this was how
you're able to host girl scout days and
reach out to local girl scout troops um
to inspire the next generation
and you know there were there were
enough of us around and excited about it
and i think it was something that we
really wanted to give to the undergrads
so that they could have the same
experience and support and love for the
organization that we did um so we were
uh led by bridget hegarty and we were
able to uh found this chapter and you
know get it recognized i began as the
grad chapter but there's a thriving
undergrad chapter and it's still there
and and women are still benefiting from
that chapter at yale and we go to the uh
annual conference each year which is
has been tremendously valuable for the
undergrads seeking employment they have
a great job fair at the sweet annual
conference um so it's kind of the
it it nurtured us in the moment when we
founded it and it gave us something to
do that we believed in um but it's still
paying off so well for for the future
generations and we're proud of that
that's amazing i yeah it's it's
phenomenal i feel like
when you start these types of new
initiatives and efforts and provide this
new support structure you always wonder
you know how is this sustainable
and it's just
it's it feels amazing to just to know
that it still exists and it's still
going and
um that's awesome i um i wanted to shift
gear a little bit more now about uh you
know being a nasa
glenn and how you're leading the study
of of solar cells so this is part of the
artemis program right correct and and um
so you're providing astronauts new
superpowers and what i mean by that
solar power um
and so how did you make the transition
from you know being in graduate school
so you know we talk about internships
and all but
it's it's remarkable because when when
you transition into this new workplace
and um and you have to adapt right i
mean we're talking about
accountability um resources are changing
your workspace is changing the people
you're engaged with um you know what are
the things you had to learn on your own
in this journey
yeah so i had to learn a lot um
but i did
come in after the experience of the phd
with
some comfort
of the research and the science and
understanding you know how to
tackle a large problem
so those were some of the tools that i
had already had um but one thing i've
i've really had to learn is how do you
nurture and manage the people on your
team um and and people are really
important to me so i wanted to do this
with tact you know when when do you push
and when do you give grace and
accommodate and i don't know that that's
something that can be taught but uh it
is something that i think is critical no
matter what we do
um then there are things about running a
research group like how do you initiate
collaborations with researchers that you
want to work with but who you don't know
personally yet who you don't have a
relationship with um and then the
administrative tax man they get me
every day that's the one thing i'm
always griping about uh and those tasks
have been greater than i anticipated i
i envisioned a life as a pi where i was
really still in the lab but i have to
fight for that time because now i have
to keep the supplies you know for
everybody else i have to make sure the
contracts are up to date so the postdocs
are getting paid and safety permits and
meetings with program managers and uh
you have to get the money and then drum
up support for more money and publish
the papers and uh traveling to give
talks around at different you know labs
and universities so it's it's been a lot
um to handle but i've been fortunate to
have you know mentors and and people
around that can give me that advice i
think it's important to try to identify
what you don't know um so that you can
get help with it uh so yeah leveraging
relationships has been really important
in this transition time for me yeah i'm
i'm i'm hearing a lot of great things
here i mean first of all the the reality
of a private investigator in the
sciences right and how
this new reality is is really wearing
many hats
learning how to manage a budget um
advocating
uh policy
managing people conflicts not just
what's happening on the bench or
projects right and and i feel like it's
a new reality that that is not just you
know in your setting for for instance
but also in academia
and i wanted to just kind of go back and
think about all the great things you've
done on campus when you're at yale you
actually
what you're you're do you did a diligent
effort to actually get
flavors of that you know through the
advanced gradual leadership fellow
program
um through some of the governance
structures you've even stored through
sui
um i feel like there's definitely you
know some sort of
linkage right and but but ultimately i
think that the one take home there is
that science is not you know it's not
that simple to begin with
on the scientific end for sure but also
on the human aspect of it and the
managerial aspect of it and then like
the many hats that we have to wear
nowadays
um yeah i know it's remarkable uh do you
have any comments though in terms of how
your experience of depth and breadth for
yale engineering has helped you
kind of just provide you know the this
um affinity to do all these different
things you're doing now at nasa
yes it's helped tremendously so i was i
realized i was in a really good position
technically because i had experience
writing papers and also as a grad
student i had experience writing grants
so that was great to come in with that
like that that experience and that
hardware to be able to to do that
and then as you mentioned you know you
kind of build up this toolbox of skills
transferable skills um that as a grad
student they were you know fun past
times and activities but then you
realize oh you know i'm able to do this
because of these previous experiences so
from you know being a resident
coordinator over the graduate housing i
had experience running you know a large
team and having a fairly large budget
with goals and milestones and making
sure those were met you know to satisfy
the needs of a community i had a lot of
experience working with diverse
individuals
you know i had also
as a resident coordinator i learned a
lot about
different marginalized identities and
what challenges other people might face
and by having to go to the different
resources on campus
i learned a lot about people
so i'm able to implement that and you
know how do we diversify stem and how to
you know i make sure that all people of
all identities feel welcome seen and
heard you know in any space that i'm
sharing with them uh so there were so
many skills uh that i was able to learn
and transfer so i'm really grateful
for that experience and and then there's
just this
the diversity of thought of that is the
yale experience and and that has
enriched my life tremendously so i had
friends you know in grad school that
were in the humanities and doing phds in
different disciplines and just from
having lunch with them or catching up
you hear what they're reading what
they're writing about and that has
enriched me so much as a person if you
probably were to look at my bookshelf
you would think i was in like the
humanities and not a scientist because i
find their work so interesting so they
kind of you know ignite this whole other
side uh of of my brain and i'm grateful
to have a better understanding of the
world that we live in and that was
absolutely acquired from yale and from
those diverse people that i met with
different studies
thank you so much yeah we talked a
little bit about that actually my
my recollection
my favorite moments really were the
first friday of five where i would just
go and mingle with people in
international relations
and in the humanities it was my favorite
part people were like oh you went you
know this is great you're doing the
biomedical engineering you're so close
to medical i'm like no i'm actually
close to the theater
that's where i want to go yes
so anyway i you know i i thank you so
much this is great i want to yield back
to to danica who has also a lot of
questions to ask thank you so much thank
you
thank you tarek and lindsay i've been so
inspired to hear you talk
more
about how you work to create the
community that you believed you could
thrive in at yale and so i wanted to ask
you sort of based on your many
experiences and stem outreach and mentor
mentoring especially as a member of sui
and ylbs and other groups while you were
at yale um what are your thoughts about
how students or recent graduates from
underrepresented communities especially
can navigate through today's stem
climate both academically uh or
professionally
yeah that's that's a great question so i
think
you know
there there are a lot of solutions to
that and i think it's really important
that
you find a
space where you can be your authentic
self um be sure to bring your authentic
self and um don't sacrifice i think a
lot of people have um
you know
there there can be external pressure to
you know be a little bit less you
whatever makes you you so you fit in
with the status quo of what you know
people may incorrectly think uh you know
is representative of the field that you
aspire to be in but i i always argue for
the opposite i think it's tremendously
important to be uniquely you because i
think that broadens the access to your
field for many other people than just
you so i think it's important you know i
am a scientist i am a woman i love
football i like makeup i like you know
and i think bringing all those things
will help someone see you know you don't
have to be a nerd you can watch you know
sunday night football and still do this
whole science thing and you can paint
your nails and still put on the lab coat
and get in the lab
so i think it's important to be
your authentic self uh find community
and make community and be community for
other people
community isn't always found where you
would like it to be um or where it
should formally be
so if you're not finding the support uh
that you would like in your department
get outside swing the doors open and you
know if you're a scientist explore other
departments in the hill and see if you
can find people you know maybe your
support system is going to be in the med
school or in the law school or with or
with people around for me the university
church was a great space for me to find
that support um and then always i was
relying on people
who had been through what i'd been
through you know i found mentors that
were in positions where i would like to
be um but i never want to overlook the
wisdom of people that are not in your
field but still have kind of navigated
through the world that we're in today so
i think you can learn a great deal
from so many people and find advocates
people who advocate for you and an
advocate is someone who will speak your
name uh
rooms that you are not there
in when opportunities come up when
awards are being discussed you know
positions that will help elevate you to
the next level
and that can be difficult to find but
it's important to try to find those
advocates
thank you for that i love this idea of
sort of busting the myth wide open about
what a scientist or what a scholar
should look like and be like
and bringing your most authentic self to
all of these spaces i think in the work
that i do i see that's a question many
many students often have is how real can
i be in these spaces and so i love that
you're offering the advice to be your
most authentic self
um just to pivot just a bit though i do
want to ask about you know gender
diversity in science and engineering um
we often talk about a leaky pipeline
referring to sort of the decreasing
proportion of women and underrepresented
minorities in stem i want to ask you
what you suggest graduate schools can do
to not only attract but also to retain
new generations of scientists
so i have been inspired to push back on
the concept of the leaky pipeline
because when we talk about a leaky
pipeline that's suggesting a passive
loss but in reality the pipeline that we
exist in has valves and they're
restricting access to some people based
on their identities and those identities
can be race sexuality gender physical
ability uh myriad things so
how do we
fix this pipeline how do we stop uh stop
this restriction of access so
i think it's uh really important to make
underrepresented students or team
members feel seen all of the time and
create an environment that is supportive
and collaborative for them
everyone should be encouraged to speak
and that they have an equal voice in the
team
i think the graduate school and all
programs should implement holistic
admissions uh processes that focus more
on research potential
by like qualitative assessments and
de-emphasize metrics like the gre and
gpa that are actually been proven to be
ineffective predictors for research
performance and degree completion uh
research has shown that letters of
recommendation are the strongest
predictor for success in graduate school
programs
so i also think we should make academic
faculty candidate lists that are diverse
we need to diversify the faculty because
that's going to aid in the retention and
recruitment of diverse students uh we
need to make sure that we're taking
serious looks at these diverse
candidates and deans and department
chairs should be rejecting short lists
that lack diversity we should i would
also encourage that you hire
or recruit your diverse candidates and
clusters so that these candidates have
cohort they also need support and
community so that they can give so much
of themselves to the department the
school their scholarship and the
students that will inevitably flock to
them for support and mentorship
so really the bottom line here is that
you need to ensure that your
organization doesn't have hidden
structures like leadership policy and
culture that are in opposition to the
mission of diversity equity and
inclusion
i love that i really feel compelled by
this idea of
a sort of a comprehensive approach to
you know providing um
pathways if you will for people to have
support and community in these spaces at
not just the student level but also at
the faculty level the idea of cluster
hires i think is really important
especially
in the stem fields
you talked a little bit about
mentors in in your life who sort of
helped you
get to where you are you talked about
your parents um
i i want to dig a little bit deeper and
find out um
more about how those mentorships have
shaped who you are now and how you pay
that forward in your life and in your
work
yeah i believe that mentoring is the
single most important thing that we do
i think it's a responsibility for all of
us
and i've been blessed to have many
mentors and a lot of times i have many
mentors at the same time working
serving different roles for me
so my parents were my first mentors and
they're still my mentors today
and from them they instilled values
within me um to value people over money
to be kind to love the environment
i had a wonderful mentor in college
professor osama itunes and he introduced
me to research and he nurtured my
curiosity
and he mentored me until he passed away
even through graduate school he was a
touch point
encouraging me and directing me because
he had been through that experience so
he knew
what that journey was like and then
professor michael loewenberg was a great
mentor for me in grad school um he was
tremendously supportive encouraging
present and a great listener uh and then
at nasa i also have wonderful mentors
and it's been great because they knew me
when i was in college so they've been
with me for like 10 years now
and they
are great mentors because they first ask
what my goals are and what i would like
to be even if that journey isn't at nasa
uh you know really what do i aspire to
do
and then they're supplying me with the
tools and guidance to help me get from
point a to b
uh so
how i pay it forward is i perform
outreach across
k-12 levels to encourage students to
pursue stem and to show them what a
scientist can look like what science is
like so that they might see themselves
in me and see themselves in the lab
i have high schoolers through post docs
that conduct research with me at nasa
and we're all learning and growing
together
gaining new skills and advancing our
careers and i think it's really easy
that for us to oversimplify or not
realize the gravity that just one touch
or one interaction can have on a student
as they move through um you know their
education and at one time in yale i gave
a lab tour to some high schoolers and
one of those high schoolers you know
reached out to me on linkedin and i'd
say every like year and a half she sends
a message you know lindsay you might not
remember me but you toured me around
your lab and i'm going to grad school
and i'm in my third year and i'm doing
this and i'm like wow you know you know
so it's it's
so valuable and there are people who you
know it's like two trains passing in the
night but
you you make an imprint on them and you
send them in a positive direction i
think we can all draw from that uh like
hartark and i were talking about you
know the hot and the cold so when things
aren't going so well um you draw from
the those positive interactions and that
encouragement and that can really help
you get through to the next sunny spot
i think it's so wonderful um the work
that you do to inspire high school
students and it's a perfect segue into
and other students as well it's a
perfect segue into one of the questions
that we received from one of the
attendees tonight i'd like to jump to it
it's very specific but this person is
asking what simplified math project
could be used to inspire
their middle school and high school
students to explore solar energy oh
that's a good question that's fine um so
a couple of things come to mind so since
you're doing math
i think you can look at solar from a lot
of different
vantage points
you can look at the economics of solar
right you know how much does a panel
cost how long is it going to take before
you know maybe your net positive on this
investment um you know maybe you want to
compare solar
power um over the lifetime
of an operating panel cradle to grave to
you know getting equivalent energy from
a coal-powered plant um so you can see
you know what is the environmental
impact what is the carbon footprint uh
you know what's what's the best route
that you could take i think you could
look at things about
you know the structure of your solar
panels how
many panels will you need to power you
know a certain load and how much is it
going to weigh how big is it going to be
how much area is it going to take up
i think that would be really fun so i
can think of a few things i also like to
think of of the human aspect in things
so
aside from costs and weight you may be
able to to think of
developing nations or the the impact of
the climate or animals
and maybe there's there's some
investigations that they could look at
there too for solar
thank you for that that's really helpful
um and tarik you can jump in at any time
we're getting questions from the
attendees tonight so i want to kind of
get to those before our our time runs
out but um someone in the q a asked um
what was your most challenging moment or
experience as a minority female student
in the sciences at yale or
you know how did you meet or overcome
that challenge
yeah i had a few challenging moments um
and
but they all had a common thread and the
common thread in these challenging
moments was
um people in positions of authority or
power or even sometimes my peers uh were
committing micro or macro aggressions
against me to make me feel
like i don't belong
so that could look like
someone coming into a lab that i'm in
even though you clearly have to be
badged and trained to have access to a
piece of equipment and asking are you a
high schooler what are you doing here
how did you get here
the person who asked me that was the
same person who trained me on the
equipment that i was a user for
and that made me feel really bad um in
that day and it was also one of those
days today back to the highs and lows
that nothing in my experiment was going
right and i didn't want to be there and
i just wanted to be in bed and it took
everything to drag myself up and you
know here comes that like straw that
brings the camel's back for the day so i
got through those times by leaning on my
support network and um that was you know
my now husband charles brown who then
was a very friendly classmate um that
provided a lot of support um and some of
my other friends that i'm still really
close to uh today and that was my
parents and those were those you know my
college professor and you reach out and
tell them you know this happened today
and this is how i'm feeling and they
dust you off and they pick you up and
maybe they give you some chocolate you
know whatever it takes to recharge you
um and get you back going so it's okay
to to feel those things and acknowledge
them um and and take a pause but i
always reminded myself that no
individual is going to knock me off of
my life's path
um i didn't want to get taken out like
that so to speak um and i refused to let
someone win you know um because it's
clear that you must not want me in this
space but i want to be here so i'm going
to fight to stay here um and i also
began
really studying the humanities more and
i read a lot of scholarship about
marginalized people because when you
start to see what the system looks like
and that this is a large system and that
it might sound like an offhand comment
someone made to you in math class but
really they're just reinforcing these
gender and race and societal things that
have been going on for hundreds of years
um i was a that knowledge in scholarship
has made me a lot more equipped to
identify and handle
those aggressions when i face them
thank you so much lindsay um you know
you were talking a lot about your
network and how important that support
system was
we have a question um from one of our
attendees who is actually this person
person's actually editing a collection
of african-americans um experiences at
yale and is curious about your awareness
or
um
your
i don't know your association with the
afro-american cultural center at yale
yes i was very much aware of and
affiliated with the house
i
found community and support in the house
i appreciated their programming um and i
had a lot of good times there i also um
hosted some events uh in the house
through the league of black scientists
and um i was a member of the boucher
uh honor society and and still am so uh
that was a
very helpful uh tool for me that was
where i met some of my first friends you
know at the welcome barbecue um very
quickly you know you get
the books the mountain of textbooks kind
of hits you in the face and you get
locked in the lab and for me that was
mason lab but i absolutely um found a
lot of of great community
through the house
thank you for answering
um
another question here what is the
culture like regarding diversity and
inclusion at nasa
yeah so that's um
that's a great question and the culture
is pretty good um the government is
actually one of the leaders in diversity
and we're
typically historically the government
has been a great place for
minoritized people to find
success
and employment and have upward mobility
um i think it's great that that's the
case i think um a government would fail
if its federal employees were not an
accurate representation of the
constituents that it represents um so
nasa is is good with that uh nasa also
has
affinity groups and support you know
networks and they facilitate these
relationships and we host listening
sessions and there are um there is a lot
of opportunity to be your authentic self
and to engage with other people that are
like you but also i feel very respected
and included by
all members all of my colleagues which
is tremendously important and one of the
other ways that i think
is more subtle but is tremendously
impactful
is
how much nasa values and uh conducts
outreach uh and that is critical to the
nasa mission we do a lot of things for k
through 12. we do a lot of things to
bring you know underrepresented students
into science get them excited about
space and expose them to them and i
think that says a lot about an
organization or agency's values when
they are doing the work to fill that
pipeline to release some of those valves
and to get everyone through and nasa
does that really well across the board
that's great it sounds like nasa has
been a really great place for you to
work and and to serve also
um we do have a question here someone
wants to know if you've ever felt
unqualified for the job or position you
were in so kind of hitting on imposter
syndrome how you were able to overcome
self-doubt if you had any
oh i've had self-doubt for sure
and and that's a tough one and
you know i think to deal with self-doubt
i
i remember everything that i've come
through to get to this point you know
i've undergone a lot of training i've
you know been to through a lot of school
i've you know faced a lot of challenges
and i'm still standing i'm still here i
find a way to get through all of it and
you didn't get through all of these
gates by accident nobody accidentally
let you into college and you didn't
accidentally graduate and you
accidentally get to grad school and you
accidentally get a job like who has that
kind of luck right um so
at a certain point you really need to
start to believe that you're not here by
a you know a clerical error uh you
earned your spot and then recall all the
things that previously seemed impossible
that you managed to do
uh and start to you know own who you are
i still have self-doubt i still get
nerves um or you get you see this
daunting task in front of you um and
also for that my family and you know my
peers that i went through grad school
with we hype each other up and we're not
hyping each other up with lies we i feel
like it's so much easier for someone
external to you to see your greatness so
if my friend calls me from grad school
and it's like i don't know how i'm gonna
do this oh my girl are you kidding me do
you remember that you did this and this
and this and he didn't even help you and
you did this and this so it's so easy to
see the greatness in someone else so let
your friends and your support network
and your family
show a mirror hold a mirror up to you
and show you your greatness and hype you
up because you've done a lot and you
will do so much more
thank you for that i know that answer
probably helped a lot of people um who
struggle with imposter syndrome so thank
you
um there's another question here from
one of the attendees and i am not a
scientist so i'm just going to read it
and let you
answer as you will but
the question is what is your opinion on
single atom catalyst
do you think that it's possible to
replace nanoparticle catalyst in the
future
so i'm actually not an expert and
catalyst so i don't have
that much to say about it but i will say
in general
i'm a fan of all technology and all
novel methods to solve problems uh one
of my least favorite things about
science um is that people have these
large sweeping opinions about what is
worthwhile to investigate and what is
trivial and what isn't that exciting and
i think that that is a show of arrogance
and oftentimes ignorance i find merit in
any discovery
gratefully when i was trained up at nasa
one thing they taught me was a null
result is a result we write it up and we
file it because if you can tell someone
that this route is a dead end that is
knowledge that we as a species need we
don't need to keep reinventing the wheel
so i am a fan of exploring all avenues
of science and i really wish that
funding agencies and people who make
those policy and decision makers also
felt that everything is worthwhile so
single catalyst go for it
thank you
tark were you gonna unmute i thought
maybe you had a question yeah yeah i was
about to i um no thank you this is this
is great i i keep having this recurring
theme of how
you know lindsay understands a lot of
times that you know a lot of people try
to push science in terms of how it
impacts society and that's good and we
look at translation we look at a lot of
things like that but the one thing that
lindsey reminds us a lot of times is
that you have to think about how society
impacts your science and how
you know whether it is at the technology
level
through holistic approaches or it is at
the human level
and talking about an active effort to
you know to figure out how to you know
to engage with everyone and make sure
that everyone's got a chance to to learn
about science it is an active effort and
this is something you have to do it you
know with intent and it's it's great to
hear all about the stories you've done
in and out nasa i the one thing you know
as you know i spent a few years in dc
doing uh supporting the federal
government and in nanoscience and then
emerging technologies and and i just
have a true appreciation for the fact
also that you probably coordinate all
across with other agencies not just at
nasa right trying to make sure
uh you can synergize efforts and and and
do all that and one one you know one of
the questions we got was what are the
advantage working as a pi at nasa rather
than a private company i i think there's
a lot and i'll let you answer it but you
know there's this global aspect you're
working in an agency that's looking at
at you know at the stars on earth i mean
it's just it's so large and so big
but i'll let you answer it
yeah thank you that's a really good
question so i think there are so many um
benefits and i'll share with you guys
some of my favorites um so one of my
uh favorite things about nasa is that we
[Music]
don't
do research for profit
um and a lot of
private places at the base of research
and development they're looking at
what will
the output of this be what can we sell
how will we make money
and it's very rare to find opportunities
where you can conduct research that
doesn't have to immediately show
how it's going to make money
so what that results in is that the
nasa funds its scientists like me to do
research that is
seen in the private sector as too high
risk because they don't know if it'll
pan out they don't quite see the vision
you know 20 30 years out
so i am thus at the cutting edge and we
get to be tremendously imaginative and
we get to think of things like what if
we printed solar cells on the moon and
it's so fun um so i really love that
opportunity
that i think is unique to being
at a government agency or specifically
at nasa um something else you know
nasa's working on space travel and i
find that tremendously exciting and the
way that we conduct research at nasa is
at first there's something called a
decadal survey so every 10 years um
people sit down and they think 10 years
out and the discussion is where what
space what science missions so like what
planets or bodies would they like to
visit in 10 years and they'll say oh
it'd be really cool if we could go to
you know europa or let's try to you know
set up camp on the moon and then from
that we divorced what technology do we
need to invent so that we can fulfill
this mission and that's where the
scientists like me you know the
engineers come in is to create this
technology such that we can conduct
those missions so we're kind of on
demand enabling um this technology and
then there's so many spin-off
technologies that we get from that you
know as we develop these things for
space we find a lot of practical uses
for them here on earth and then we spin
them out um again to companies that end
up boosting the economy and giving us
you know this great new technology um
that
probably would not have been discovered
if they didn't if we didn't have that
latitude and that freedom of imagination
to think so wonky and so far out of the
box and to be so creative
and i also love that nasa really values
people the environment in the community
so it's tremendously important to me as
a person that i am doing little to no
harm to our earth um and i appreciate
working at a place that's not polluting
you know not uh robbing resources and
not you know being a negative presence
on our planet um so i really appreciate
just the values of of our agency
this is great i i you know what i've
been hearing
um also is something that resonates
actually in other disciplines i feel
like
you know it goes back to that question
about the you know the single item stuff
versus the article i mean a lot of times
you want to think about the problem
and then think about the challenge in
general and think about what makes sense
just like what you do in
in biotechnology for example what does
the biology tell you
and then figure out what makes sense in
terms of what technologies you want to
develop to treat this disease and
and i think i you know i've been you
know you don't you don't try to push a
particular platform just just for the
sake of it being cool right and i so i
love that i i'm also hearing the fact
that you know
your your passion for the environment
and and thinking about policy and
everything i mean i can imagine for
example that
taking a step back you're probably
engaging for example with epa or other
did you ever have an instance where you
were like you know you're you're
actually affecting policy at a higher
level
yeah so i think you know that's
something also i appreciate about being
with the government is we are the eyes
and ears and the checkpoints of the
government so um we're the subject
matter experts that
you know our our leaders our you know
congressional leaders and our lawmakers
and our policymakers rely on to say is
this good uh should we be doing this
maybe we should not be doing this should
we fund this more is this you know what
direction should we be going in so i
appreciate uh being in that position and
although i can say those are wings that
i'm still growing and i haven't entirely
you know taken off on that yet that's
something that i'm really excited and
passionate about because i think these
decisions need to be made thinking about
the
long-term longevity of our
species we need to be thinking about
everyone this you know any technology
any large decisions or directions we
take need to benefit all people um so
these are some of the things that i'm
really interested in and there are
opportunities for that cross-pollination
um you know nasa is sometimes seen as
the wonkier folks when we do sit down
because we're with you know the air
force army you know and the navy and
they have their viewpoint of the world
and we're literally over here like let's
just hold hands you know wouldn't it be
cool if and so we're we're a bit of the
flower child in that way but i think
we're really valuable in that sense
that's great thank you we actually
i have a a really really fun question
here from the colorado yale association
um
have you watched a new june movie and
you like science fiction fiction or
afrofuturism i love it by the way have i
watched which movie the new june
oh
yes i did watch that and it was fun i've
really been getting into um sci-fi
lately i've been reading it a bit more
uh than watching movies because that's a
bit more of my speed but yeah i enjoyed
that movie and i um i also love sci-fi
and i
get really excited by sci-fi they
they provide a lot of like information
and perspectives and kind of uh
situations that i hadn't considered yet
um and then i'm like is this could this
happen is this real like maybe we could
so then i'm amped up and i want to go
into the lab and try to make it happen
um so yeah i i'm a big fan
that's really cool yeah i'm a big fan of
the movie i i really just i i was on my
seat all the time and that was just wow
it was it was great um all right well i
don't know dan again do you think we we
have room maybe like one last question
maybe for one last question lindsay
thank you uh for that answer i i must
admit i do not know that popular
cultural reference so i'm gonna have to
catch up on dune it sounds like
something i should be into
um but just for one you know closing
question here it's a it's a big one but
i'm hoping that
you'll have a succinct answer
what is the one piece of advice you
would give to yale students in the
audience
oh that's a great one
i'm going to cheat and give one personal
advice and one professional advice um so
the personal advice i would tell yale
students is remember
that life goes on while you're in grad
school um so this is like four to seven
plus ten ish years that you're that
you're there but time isn't going to
stand still so nurture relationships
with your family and your friends and be
sure you take time for them because
they're aging they're moving they're
going through life
and those milestones that we experience
as people are tremendously valuable
professionally i would say listen um
listen to things that you don't think
are necessarily relevant to your field
of study or your goals or your career or
your life there's just so much to learn
from every discipline
and the world we live in is tremendously
interdisciplinary so i pull from various
fields in science in my research
and humanities scholarship continues to
provide me with a road map to life as i
navigate through so be sure you listen a
lot and have fun and learn something new
thank you so much lindsay i think i can
speak for everyone and say this has been
delightful
um
everything you've said today i think has
been so impactful um and i'm taking
personally away
a lot that a lot from this conversation
so we just appreciate you um giving of
your time and being so generous um with
your research and uh your
sort of mentorship and outreach
initiatives and sort of helping us to
really understand how to create spaces
for us um and for for students to create
spaces especially that are nurturing and
will help them thrive while here at yale
i also want to thank lynn cooley
i want to thank tarek for being such a
great co-moderator with me
and thank you all for the questions
submitted it made for a very lively and
important conversation
to all the students and alumni who tuned
in tonight i hope you've enjoyed the
discussion and will continue to help us
build a stronger community
among graduate students
faculty and alumni at yale i'd also like
to invite you to
the graduate school's graduate student
reach across disciplines webinar which
will happen on december 8th and i
believe we're going to drop the link for
the registration for that webinar in the
chat if you'd like to sign up
before we sign off tonight i'd like to
remind anyone who has not already done
so
to join cross campus yale's online
networking community building and
mentoring program across campus is a
fantastic way
for alumni and students to connect with
one another
and if there are other ways in which
you'd like to be more involved in
supporting the graduate school please
reach out to us
send us an email at gsas.yale.edu
we look forward to hearing from you soon
and to gathering with you again
thank you all for being here this
evening